[Musique]
on a une disponibilité très basse du
parc nucléaire avec quasiment un
réacteur nucléaire sur deux à l'arrêt on
a aussi une vigilance particulière sur
notre capacité à importer de
l'électricité depuis les pays voisins et
ça c'est lié à la crise énergétique
russe et à l'alimentation en gaz on
anticipe une possibilité de devoir
couper la consommation des Français pour
pour garantir cet équilibre production
égale consommation et donc on s'apprête
à passer un hiver exceptionnel avec une
vigilance vraiment exceptionnelle sur
l'ensemble de la période hivernale
on a développé un site internet mon
ecowatt.fr on a développé également une
application Ecowatt qui va permettre à
chacun d'adapter sa consommation
d'électricité en fonction de la météo de
l'électricité et qui reflètera le niveau
de tension du système électrique pendant
tout l'hiver
[Musique]
deux volets dans ecowatts le premier
violet c'est une la météo de
l'électricité sous forme de signaux vers
orange ou rouge et qui permettront à
chacun de savoir pour la journée en
cours et pour les trois journées à venir
le niveau de risque du système
électrique signal vert tout va bien
signal orange quand on fait la somme de
ce que tous les Français vont consommer
les particuliers les collectivités les
entreprises on se rapproche de la
capacité de production maximale
disponible en France et puis éco-watt
rouge signal rouge c'est que là par
contre quand on prévoit la consommation
des Français on va dépasser le niveau de
production maximum disponible en France
et donc là il y a un risque fort d'être
obligé de couper les Français de couper
particulier collectivités entreprises
pour arriver à retrouver un équilibre du
système
[Musique]